let's say that I have two non zero
vectors say the first Wester is X the
second vector is why they're both a part
of or a set they're both in the set are
N and they're nonzero non zero it turns
out that the absolute value of their let
me do it in a different color the
absolute let me do it in a this color is
nice the absolute value of their dot
product of the two vectors the absolute
value remember this is just a scalar
quantity is less than or equal to the
product of their lengths and we've
defined the dot product and we've
defined lengths already it's less than
or equal to the product of their lengths
and and just to push it'll even further
the only time that this is equal so the
dot product the dot product of the two
vectors is only going to be equal to the
length so this you know the equal in the
less than or equal apply only in the
situation let me write that down only in
the situation where one of these vectors
is a scalar multiple of the other or
they're collinear they're just you know
that one's just kind of the longer a
shorter version of the other one so only
in the situation where let's just say X
is equal to some scalar multiple of Y
and this this these inequalities or is I
guess this is the quality and this
inequality this is called the Cauchy
Schwarz inequality
kocchi kocchi Schwarz inequality
inequality so let's prove it because you
can't take something like this just at
face value you shouldn't just accept
that so let me just construct a somewhat
artificial function let me construct
some function of some that's a that's a
that's a function of some variable some
scalar t let me define P of T to be
equal to the length of the vector T T
times the vector some scalar T times the
vector Y
- the vector X it's the length of this
vector this is going to be a vector now
is it that squared now before I move
forward I want to make a little one
little point here if I take the length
of any vector of any real vector so the
length of any real vector I'll do it
here let's say I take the length of some
vector V I want you to accept that this
is going to be a positive number so it's
at least greater than or equal to zero
because this is just going to be each of
its terms squared V 2 squared all the
way to VN squared all of these are real
numbers when you square a real number
you get something greater than or equal
to zero and then you sum them up you're
going to have something greater than or
equal to zero and you take the square
root of it the principal square root the
positive square root you're gonna have
something greater than or equal to zero
so the length of any real vector is
going to be greater than or equal to
zero so this is the length of a real
vector so this is going to be greater
than or equal to zero now in the
previous video I think it was two videos
ago I also showed that the magnitude or
the length of a vector squared can also
be re-written as the dot product of that
vector with itself so let's rewrite this
vector that way so this is equal to the
the length of this vector squared is
equal to the dot product of that vector
with itself so it's T Y minus X dot T Y
minus X in the last video I showed you a
bunch of I showed you that you can treat
a multiplication or you can treat the
dot product very similar to regular
multiplication when it comes to the
associative distributive and commutative
properties so when you multiply these
you know you can kind of use these
multiplying these two binomials you can
do it the same way as you would just
multiply two regular algebraic binomials
you're essentially just using the
distributive property so if you're but
you remember this isn't just regular
multiplication this is the dot product
we're doing this is vector
multiplication or one version of vector
multiplication so if we distribute it
out this will become T Y dot T Y so let
me write that out
we'll be T Y dot T Y and then we'll get
a - a mine let me do it this way then we
get the - x times this T Y so you get or
let me instead of saying taht times I
should be very careful say dot so - X
dot T Y and then you end up and then you
have the this T Y times this minus X so
then you have minus T Y dot X and then
finally you have the X's dot with each
other and it's you can view them as
minus one X dot minus One X so you could
say plus minus One X right I could just
say view this is plus minus one or plus
minus one so this is minus One X dot
minus One X so let's see so this is what
my whole expression simplified to or
expanded to I can't really call this a
simplification but we can use the fact
that this is commutative and associative
to rewrite this expression right here
this is equal to Y dot y y dot Y times T
squared right T is just a scalar - - and
actually this is - these two things are
equivalent right if they're just
rearrangements of the same thing and we
saw that the dot product is associative
so this is just equal to two times x dot
y times t and i should do that and maybe
a different color so these two terms
result in that term right there and then
you have them if you just rearrange
these you have a minus one times a minus
one they cancel out so those would come
com+ and you're just left with plus X
dot X and I should do that in a
different color as well I'll do that
orange color so those terms end up with
that term right then of course that term
results in that term and remember all I
did is I rewrote this thing and said
look this has got to be equal
greater than or equal to zero so I can
rewrite that here this is this thing is
still just the same thing I've just
rewritten it so this is all going to be
greater than or equal to zero
now let's make a little bit of a
substitution just to clean up our
expression a little bit and we'll later
back substitute into this let's define
this as a let's define this piece right
here as B so the whole thing minus two x
dot y I'll leave the T there and let's
define this or let me just define let me
define this right here see X dot X as C
so then what is our expression become it
becomes a times T squared minus I'm
going to be careful with the colors B
times T plus C plus C and of course we
know that it's going to be greater than
or equal to zero it's the same thing as
this up here greater than or equal to
zero I could write P of T here P of T
now this is greater than or equal to
zero for any for any T that I put in
here for any real T that I put in there
and so I could just put in I could just
put in let me just pick a T to be let me
take let me evaluate our function at B
over 2a and I can definitely do this
because what was a I just have to make
sure I'm not dividing by zero anyplace
so a was this this vector dotted with
itself and we said this is a nonzero
vector so this is the square of its
length
it's a nonzero vector so some of these
terms up here would end up becoming
positive when you take its length so
this thing right here is nonzero this is
a nonzero vector then two times the dot
product with itself is also going to be
nonzero so we can do this we don't have
to worry about dividing by zero or
whatever else but what does this be
equal to this will be equal to and I'll
just stick to the green it takes too
long to keep switching between colors
this is equal to a times this expression
squared so it's B squared over 4a
squared
I just squared two way to get 4a squared
minus
B times this so B time this is just
regular multiplication B times B over 2a
I'll just write in regular
multiplication there plus C and we know
all of that is greater than or equal to
zero now if we simplify this a little
bit what do we get
well this a cancels out with this
exponent there and you end up with a B
squared right there so we get B squared
over 4a minus B squared over 2a that's
that term over there plus C is greater
than or equal to zero and I let me
rewrite this I could if I multiply the
numerator denominator this by two what
do I get I get 2b squared over 4a and
the whole reason I did that is because
to get a common denominator here so what
do you get you get B squared over 4a
minus 2 B squared over 4a so what is
what are these two terms simplify to
well the numerator is B squared minus 2
B squared so that just becomes minus B
squared over 4a plus C is greater than
or equal to 0 these two terms add up to
this one right here now if we add this
to both sides of the equation we get C
is greater than or equal to V squared
over 4a right there's a negative on the
left hand side if I add it to both sides
it's going to be a positive on the right
hand side so we're already we're
approaching something that looks like an
inequality so let's back substitute our
original substitutions to see what we
have now so where as are my original
substitutions that I made I was right
here so what was and actually just to
simplified any more let me multiply both
sides by 4a and once I set once again I
said a not only is it nonzero it's going
to be positive this is the square of its
length and I already showed you that the
length of any vector and real any real
vector is going to be positive and the
reason why I'm taking great pains to
show that a is positive is because if I
multiply both sides of it I don't want
to change the inequality sign so let me
multiply both sides of this by a before
I substitute so we get 4 AC is greater
than or equal to
be squared there you go and I remember I
took great pains I just said a is
definitely a positive number because it
is essentially the square of the length
y dot y is the square of the length of y
and that's the positive value it has to
be positive for dealing with real
vectors now let's back substitute this
so 4 times a 4 times y dot y Y dot y is
also I might as well just write it there
y dot y is the same thing as the
magnitude of Y squared that's why dot y
this is a why do I showed that I showed
you that in a previous video times si si
is X dot X X dot X well X dot X is the
same thing as the length of vector x
squared so this was C so four times a
times C is going to be greater than or
equal to B squared
now what was B B was this thing here so
B squared would be 2 times X dot y
squared so we've gotten to this result
so far and so what can we do with this
so oh sorry this whole thing is squared
this whole thing right here was B so
let's see if we can simplify this so we
get on switched to a different color
four times the length of Y squared times
the length of x squared is greater than
or equal to if we square this quantity
right here we get 4 times X dot Y 4
times X dot Y times X x dot y actually
even better let me just write it like
this let me just write 4 times X dot y
squared now we can divide both sides by
4 that won't change our inequality so
that just cancels out there and now
let's take the square root of both sides
of this equation so the square roots of
both sides of this equation these are
positive values so the square root of
this side is the square root of each of
its terms that's just a
property so if you take the square root
of both sides you get the length of Y
times the length of X is greater than or
equal to the square root of this and
we're going to take the positive square
root we're going to take the positive
square root on both sides of this
equation that keeps us from having to
mess with anything on the inequality or
anything like that so the positive
square root is going to be the absolute
value absolute value of XY and I want to
be very careful to say this is the
absolute value because it's possible
that this thing right here this thing
right here wasn't as a negative value
but when you square it you you you know
you want to make be careful that when
you take the square root of it that you
stay a positive value because otherwise
you have to when we take it with the
principal square root we might mess with
the inequality so this is we're taking
the positive square root which will be
so if you take the absolute value
ensuring that it's going to be positive
but this is our result the absolute
value of the dot product of our vectors
is less than the product of the two
vectors length so we got our cauchy's
warts inequality so we got our caoxi
Schwarz inequality now the last thing I
said is look what happens what happens
if what happens if X is equal to some
scalar multiple of Y well in that case
what's the absolute value the absolute
value of x dot y well that equals that
equals what if we make the substitution
that equals the absolute value of C
times y that's just X dot Y which is
equal to which is equal to just from the
associative property it's equal to the
absolute value of C times we want to
make sure absolute values take
everything keep everything positive y
dot y and well this is just equal to C
times C times the magnitude of Y or the
length of Y squared
well that just is equal to that is just
equal to the magnitude of C
times though or the absolute value of
our scalar C times our length of Y times
our length of Y times our length of Y
well this right here this I can rewrite
this I mean you can prove this to
yourself if you don't believe it but
this we could put the C inside of the
magnitude and that could be a good
exercise for you to prove but it's
pretty straightforward you just do the
definition of length and you multiply it
by C this is equal to the magnitude of C
Y times let me say the length of C Y
times the length of Y length of Y I've
lost my vector notation someplace over
here
I lost my there you go now this is X so
this is equal to the length of X times
the length of Y so I showed you kind of
the second part of the Cauchy Schwarz
inequality that this is only equal to
each other if one of them is a scalar
multiple of the other and if you thought
if you're a little uncomfortable some of
these steps I took it might be a good
exercise to actually prove it for
example to prove that the absolute value
of C times the length of the vector Y is
the same thing as the length of C times
y anyway hopefully you found this pretty
useful the Cauchy Schwarz inequality
will use a lot when we prove other
results in linear algebra and in a
future video I'll give you a little more
intuition about why this makes a lot of
sense relative to the dot product